[Music]
well good evening welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight for the past couple of
years we've reported in some detail some
horrifying detail on how the
professional left has totally
transformed the city of San Francisco
from this country's most beautiful city
our Cape Town into a cesspool of Filth
homelessness and drug addiction that is
not an exaggeration there are no more
junkies in San Francisco than there are
high school students and so you won't be
surprised to learn that the city has
also become threatening and dangerous
the rate of property crime in San
Francisco is the highest of any big city
in America more than five dozen cars are
smashed and robbed every single day of
the year
it's a disaster but don't worry the
city's leaders have a plan to respond to
this of course it's not more cops or
better enforcement of the law that would
be bigoted instead the city of San
Francisco has decided to ban words that
suggest San Francisco has a crime
problem people aren't allowed to talk
about crime maybe they won't notice
crime exists that's the thinking so last
month the city's Board of Supervisors
decreed that there will be no more
convicted felons in San Francisco
going forward ex-cons are to be called
quote justice-involved individuals well
as it happens the people they committed
crimes against are also quote
justice-involved individuals so in other
words victim and criminal are now
morally indistinguishable that's on
purpose this is woke equality but
there's a problem
back in Washington leaders the
Democratic Party apparently haven't
gotten the memo on this and some are
still using the term felon which is the
real f-word so you might want to send
the kids from the room as we play the
following clip we warn you it's ugly
an overwhelming majority of Americans
agree that anyone trying to buy a gun
should at least have to prove that
they're not a or somebody legally
prohibited from owning one and I do
support full restoration of rights to
vote I think the policy
made sense for all those young men
mostly of color who got arrested and are
now for life for selling that weed on
the corner every law-abiding citizen has
a right to have a gun unless you're what
enabled that young man to get a gun he
was not entitled to he was eighth and he
had a conviction sorry about all the F
words how insensitive can you get
someone better call HR meanwhile back in
the city of San Francisco they're no
longer any juvenile delinquents that
whole category has disappeared criminals
under 18 are now referred to as quote
young people impacted by the juvenile
justice system as if the system and not
the kid committed the crime which is
what the left in fact believes it's your
fault not theirs check your priveledge
middle america drug addicts meanwhile in
San Francisco are now called people with
the history of substance abuse rather
use use not abuse get it heroin addicts
are now the same as insulin dependent
diabetic s' both use substances you
can't call one better than the other
they're both exactly the same now you
could laugh this off at San Francisco
after all all the crazy things happen
but thanks for the implications language
makes thought possible when the words
disappear so does our ability to think
about the ideas the words represent when
they prevent you from saying the obvious
over time it becomes impossible to see
the obvious
and that's exactly of course why they do
it those who control your words control
your mind